Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux.
J'adore l'ouvrir
l'huître et aussi la déguster.
Comme les deux tiers des Français,
quelle que soit la saison,
je ne résiste pas à leur parfum
et leur petit goût iodé.
En plus, on leur prête beaucoup de vertus,
on les dit même aphrodisiaques.
Casanova, paraît-il, en manger une douzaine chaque matin.
Alors, info ou intox ?
On va essayer d'y voir plus clair.
Il fait chaud aujourd'hui.
Il existe deux variétés d'huîtres en France.
Les huîtres plates et les huîtres creuses.
Plates, creuses.
Ça se voit, non ?
Les premières vivaient en nombre le long des côtes françaises jusqu'au XIXᵉ siècle.
Malheureusement, elles ont été victimes
de leur succès et aussi de maladies.
Du coup, elles sont devenues rares.
Aujourd'hui,
elles sont encore élevées en Bretagne.
Ce sont les fameuses Belon,
par exemple, du nom d'un petit
fleuve côtier à l'embouchure
duquel elles se développent.
Ces huîtres ont été remplacées
le long des côtes et dans nos assiettes,
par des huîtres creuses, d'abord
par une espèce originaire du Portugal,
puis par une espèce originaire
des côtes japonaises.
Pas facile ton truc.
Si vous aimez les huîtres,
dites moi lesquelles vous préférez.
En attendant un peu d'histoire...
Ça fait longtemps qu'on aime les huîtres.
Au XIXᵉ siècle,
Louis XVIII en consommait tellement qu'on le surnommait :
Louis dix huîtres !
Un de ses prédécesseurs, Louis XV, les aime tant,
qu'en 1727, il commande un tableau intitulé : Le Déjeuner d'huîtres.
Il est exécuté par le peintre
Jean-François de Troy
et destiné à orner la salle à manger
des petits appartements de Versailles.
J'adore ce tableau.
Il figurait dans un de mes livres
d'histoire quand j'étais collégien.
Il est plein de vie.
On y voit d'ailleurs
l'une des premières représentations
d'une bouteille de champagne.
On aura sûrement l'occasion d'y revenir.
Il est aujourd'hui
visible au musée Condé à Chantilly.
A l'époque,
les camions frigorifiques n'existent pas.
Les huîtres sont transportées
en charrettes tirées par des chevaux.
La route est longue, entre 24h et 36h
pour faire la liaison Dieppe Paris.
L'hiver, ça va.
Mais l'été, quand les huîtres arrivent
dans la capitale,
elles ne sont plus toutes fraîches.
D'autant qu'à l'époque,
les huîtres ne sont pas toujours vendues
dans leur coquille, mais huîtrées ou en panier comme l'on dit.
C'est-à-dire décoquillées pour être mangées en ragoût.
Pour lutter contre les intoxications
causées par le coquillage pendant la belle saison,
Louis XV interdit donc la pêche,
le colportage ou la vente des huîtres,
de la fin avril à la fin août.
Pas d'huîtres les mois sans R. C'est l'origine
d'un usage qui a longtemps duré.
Même si aujourd'hui, il n'y a plus
aucun risque à manger des huîtres l'été,
à condition bien sûr de respecter la chaîne du froid.
Bon, je te rappelle qu'on voudrait savoir
si les huîtres sont aphrodisiaques.
Et pour le moment, c'est pas très sexy
ton histoire.
L'histoire d'amour avec l'huître
ne date pas d'aujourd'hui.
On la soupçonne d'avoir des effets
sur la libido depuis l'Antiquité.
Vénus serait, selon certains auteurs,
l'incarnation humaine de la perle.
Du coup, elle ne serait pas sortie d'une coquille Saint-Jacques comme la peint Botticelli,
mais d'une huître !
Bon, ok, mais alors qu'est ce que je fais ?
Je me change ou je reste dans cette tenue ?
À ta place, je me changerais.
Jusqu'à présent,
les scientifiques n'ont pas pu prouver
que consommer des huîtres augmente
le désir sexuel.
Sa réputation aphrodisiaque n'est donc pas fondée.
En revanche,
100 grammes de chair d'huîtres,
soit l'équivalent de huit...
de huit... de huit huîtres.
Pas facile à dire.
Apporte plus de 20 milligrammes de zinc.
C'est beaucoup.
Les nutritionnistes en recommandent
un apport quotidien
de 11 milligrammes pour les hommes et 8 pour les femmes.
Et quel rapport ?
Les scientifiques ont montré
que cet oligo élément contribue
chez les hommes à maintenir un niveau plus élevé de testostérone,
l'hormone associée à la sexualité
et à la fertilité masculine.
Et puis, ils ont aussi noté
que chez les souris, le zinc augmente
le nombre de spermatozoïdes et leur mobilité.
Mais rien de plus.
Quoi qu'il en soit, ça ne doit pas
vous empêcher de manger des huîtres.
Ce qui est certain, c'est que les huîtres
sont riches en vitamines B et A,
en fer, en phosphore, en cuivre, en oméga 3, en iode.
Elles sont faibles en calories.
Elles affichent une bonne
teneur en protéines.
Bref,
à défaut
de pimenter votre libido, elles boosteront vos menus par leurs bienfaits.
Avec deux kilogrammes par personne
et par an en moyenne, les Français
sont les premiers consommateurs
d'huîtres au monde.
Que vous aimiez les huîtres ou non,
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo et à vous abonner.
Quant à moi, je vous laisse.
Il faut que je participe
à l'effort collectif
pour garder la tête du classement.